hey guys welcome back to evan and
caitlin podcast episode 69 the nicest
podcast you'll listen to today
nice
[Music]
so today we're going to be talking about
trying to be perfect versus trying
new things that you aren't that good at
but first we have an update
this mainly can affect people who are
looking at the podcast
and watching it on youtube it doesn't
really affect the audio quality
but we have changed the setup again
yes so now our camera's a lot closer to
us
meaning we can lean forward and get
really intense with the camera
evan can point and his finger is huge
and that's just like
the side effect of why we made the
change when we first
built and set up this desk it was for
this podcast this is the humble origins
of
this desk and over the
years yes years
over a year and a half it has evolved a
lot
because of our evan and katelyn gaming
that we do we have added
monitor after monitor after monitor
audio
everywhere and now that caitlyn and i
are both
playing almost every single stream
we'll often have to like move keyboards
back and forth or both of our screens
will be over there and we're looking at
it weird
and it's just not good ergonomically and
for like
something that we do uh two to three
days a week for
two to four hours it's just like not
good to have bad ergonomics for that
long
so we now have two keyboards one here
one there
and the third for this anyway i'm just
gonna stop you when you say one here one
there
and no one can even see what people are
watching what you're referencing anyways
everything is like square now like we're
facing straight forward to see our
screens instead of looking off to the
sides
it's nice great but the side effect of
that is because our screens are right in
front of us we used to have the camera
on the other side of the room
obviously our faces would be blocked
with the screens right in front of us so
now the camera
is right between the screens what's
really funny is i think that there was
a stream or a podcast or something where
i said
i'm done messing with things and that
was like
five iterations of this desk ago
we've added the cat cam anyways i've
just like given up
ever saying i'm not gonna change
anything and if you hear him say it
don't trust it don't trust it because
i'm gonna change things in the future
we're gonna keep on trying to
uh you know keep this set up as good for
us and as great for you as possible
um but moving on to the main topic
trying to be perfect
versus trying new things you're not good
at hey that actually is a great segue
because
when we set up this desk we didn't set
out to make it perfect
yeah we just started and we figured
things out
as we went and i think that's one way to
do things
um but for our videos it's hard for us
to keep on doing the same thing
over and over and over again and
iterating a bajillion times like we have
with this desk because
that doesn't make the most interesting
video you know just like this desk we
made the very first video where we
showed it set up
and it looks nothing like that anymore
but we couldn't have made a video every
single time we made a single change
and at the same time like when do you
make the update video because it's
always going to change
i don't know so updates updates are one
thing like updates you do over time but
another way to look at it
um that is applicable to what we do but
also like could be applicable to what
you do
is um within one project
like when do you call it good enough and
when do you like
give into your perfectionism well i
think that that goes back to like
your vision when you first started did
you have the vision of
you know i am going to um start
doing clay sculptures and i'm going to
practice that until i'm a master
and in that case you just do one then
you do another then you do another and
you just keep on making
each one the best that you can and then
starting over and trying again
if it's just to have fun then stop
when like right before your
you've reached peak happiness you know
i know like they're there before you've
reached peak happiness yeah yeah
yeah because like that's the thing it's
like when you're eating a meal you know
it's a little different than working on
a project that'd be like if i if i was
like
ugh i'm 90 done time to stop oh okay
well
that's per project i'm thinking like
like um
like if you're if you're working on a
whole bunch of paintings and you're
enjoying the first one
the second one and the third one if you
like go too far
then like you've you've just worn
yourself out and you might not be
working the best that you can and you're
like
i don't enjoy this anymore whereas if
you stop early enough
and you're not like overly fatigued and
and overly fatigued and like worn out
then you still like want to paint again
in the future whereas like if every time
you work on something
you like wear yourself out you'll slowly
start to sour on that i think
yeah i could see that it is that is
comparable to the food example of like
pizza is great but if you have pizza
every night you're not
gonna be liking it or even within one
meal like there is a point at which
you've eaten more pizza and then you
think back on all the pizza you've eaten
you kind of regret it although that's
rare pizza is like a rare exception to
that
but in terms of like us personally
um we are a strange example to look at
just because
we make content for a living and
you know the projects that we do are
just an excuse to make a video
in some ways but also the two of us are
artists
so we can also be a little
perfectionistic about how our projects
turn out
yeah and you know i'll say thankfully
and luckily
most of the projects that we do i am
very happy with the results of yeah i'm
i'm usually pretty pleased
but i think yeah i think one reason we
are thinking about this
is well there's a few like current
reasons but one of them
is um the video we put out most recently
the opel pop sockets
yeah one thing that we talked about in
our patreon after show but we've
continued to think about it
is like we were just really tempted to
keep going and keep going
and there's so many more things we would
have tried but we held ourselves back
because we thought that it wouldn't make
for as good of a
video yeah because even three iterations
caitlin had a cut
a lot out like so much out
and and if we have done like six
iterations
then it was just very subtle differences
it's like it just wouldn't have made for
that much better of a video even though
the result we might have been more happy
with it and it would have really
complicated caitlyn's editing and it
might have made the video worse in a way
and you might be able you might just say
like well
just show the first two attempts don't
show the next
three and then show the last one yeah
you know what i mean
but you don't you never know when the
last is yeah sometimes that works and
sometimes it it
doesn't and you might in that last one
refer to things that happened in the
ones that were skipped
or you might like you might be filming
one of them and like a hilarious moment
happens and you don't want to cut it
because it was a really hilarious moment
or like you
you ruined something or you know like so
you you can't guarantee you can cut
stuff and i guess like you can
fill in the blanks with like vo and
stuff like that but
yeah just like time lapse the whole
thing and add vo or something
yeah but then if you get that point
where you're just time-lapsing the whole
thing is that is that that
it's not our content it's not our style
you know not that it's bad but it's not
like our style
yeah we have so so little of our videos
is without us talking
you know what i mean so little of it is
just only be roller only time lapse with
no
audio so we can't do that too much yeah
and i think that like how it might
relate to other people is
i mean i i think for us not being good
at something
often holds us back from from trying
um now us less than most people because
like sometimes
us trying something and failing leads to
good content
but like at the end of the video we need
some sort of a win
you know like if we don't think that we
can get to a win
in a single video um standard length of
timing it's like sometimes we won't
tackle that thing because we're like
well
yeah we just don't have the time to
spare if it doesn't work out don't have
the time and i think that that is a
common thing that most people can relate
to because like
most people don't have like a limited
amount of free time like
a limited amount of time where they can
put towards hobbies or
learning a new skill or what have you
and like not many people
are gonna like just jump straight into
like making a rocking chair
you know it's like i mean that's not
maybe the best example um let's see
uh i don't know it might be hard for
someone to jump into resin art
if they have never done it it's an
investment it requires time
you know whatever the thing may be yeah
um but yeah it is it is interesting
um uh because you know one thing about
i'll go back to that that video again is
we got so many suggestions of like ooh
you guys should try this and do this and
maybe if you did this and this and i'm
like those are all good ideas yeah but
and like if we had thought of that
beforehand it might have led to a
better end result but i do wonder if we
knew all of that beforehand
like if we knew how to do it perfectly
in one
try and then it was done would that be
as interesting of a video because
sometimes we go back and forth about
like
should we do some small tests before we
start filming
because that means we get some practice
in
especially with the new material we get
used to the new material we
can maybe try out a few techniques and
then go into the video
that might end up with a better result
but then we lose the
experimenting and we lose any upfront
mistakes and that's something that we
like to include so we're
we're always trying to strike that
balance where we're going in
like as much noobs as possible
about the project where while still
having done like
the minimal amount of research to be
able to do the thing
you know it's just like a hard balance
also i mean there's a ton of videos of
like
experts trying whatever you know we're
trying often but there aren't many
people
of like you know hey i'm trying this for
my first time and i'm gonna document
and show all of my failures so also in a
way it's like
if i think that if we went with like you
know
practicing and getting really good at
something and then making the video one
would just make a whole lot less videos
because it takes time to practice yeah
they wouldn't be as unique
and you know i'm not sure if they'd
fulfill the same
you know niche that we are feeling right
now well that's interesting to think
about because
we do have a couple videos
where we know how to do the
quote unquote project we know how it's
going to turn out the main thing i can
think of
are our first two cooking videos which
are doing our magic broccoli and our
vodka sauce
that's totally different maybe the
reason that that is different
because you know we obviously know the
recipe we know how it was going to turn
out we still were able to have fun
and banter and goof around i think
that's a little bit harder with some of
the maker projects because
um like
uh most of the fun in banter in the
maker projects
comes from the experimental parts
because the other parts like
cutting wood and measuring and things
like that you can't
really have those interactions during
those times yeah we often montage
through that because it is harder to
like
extract good content like i don't know
we're trying to make sure we cut things
i don't want to like say that all right
now i'm going to cut this now i'm going
to drill this and the reason why is
well you can see like i don't need to
say it because you can visually see it
yeah but also we just can't like
distract each other
during those times we have to like you
know safety is
something we have to keep in mind and
things like that so if we cut out the
experimental parts is it as fun
whereas something like vodka sauce i
mean
i guess we could like burn a finger but
the steaks are much lower and we don't
have to
you know if we if we scoop a little bit
less pasta than normal
it's not gonna our chair's not gonna
fall apart you know what i mean yeah
and i'm looking back at our videos and i
really don't see like it like you said
i don't see almost anything except for
the cooking
where are we gonna where are we there's
one what's that
and that's an actual project um and it's
way
back it was one of our very early videos
oh the ghost the ghost
the ghost i really had so much fun
filming that it was so relaxed and easy
i think another reason that that one
worked
is because um we could distract each
other
by just like messing around because it
was just like
taping and cutting things with scissors
yeah like yeah we could just
goof around and have fun we made these
little like floating ghosts outdoor
ghosts that hang in your tree for
halloween
yeah and i guess we we could
have done that maybe with the pop
sockets
because like you know it was uv resin
there wasn't any like
cutting and stuff but there is you know
it was still like a brand new material
and i don't know i don't really know the
answer like we're definitely still
trying to figure out the balance i want
to
i want to try to practice see if we can
go back to some past things
like let's do another infinity something
like
as an infinity light yeah yeah like you
like you know how we did the infinity
galaxy
black hole table like it'd be fun to do
infinity something again it'd be fun to
but then again we might do the infinity
something but then add another
you know new thing perhaps i don't know
well and that's not the best example
because
with the infinity mirror portion of the
black hole galaxy table
that was basically montage through
because
experimenting with like led lights and
programming them
yeah all the experimenting was in the
programming yeah and i did all of that
off screen anyway yeah you did it all
off screen anyways
oh i think a better example would be um
like like could we ever do pendulum
painting again here's a real example
all right but i forgot what was the
second thing we did this on hold on you
scroll so
um for our diy rainbow bench we tried
rainbow staining wood for the first time
yeah
and then in the tensegrity table we used
that same rainbow stain
on the wood yeah we had already learned
it that you know we couldn't make a
whole video about it again
yeah you know yeah just do another no it
was just a little bit of spice
on top of this integrity table it wasn't
like the meat of it
yeah and the reason why we can do like
resin art again and again and again
is because in different ways in
different ways but also it's like
every single time is different and
unique we're trying for new thing
it's so unpredictable it's so like yeah
it's it's it's new every time almost you
know because we're using in different
ways and there's so much we can do with
it i think that's one reason
why we are drawn to resin and why we
kind of have been since we first tried
it a couple years ago
and i know like you know people will
tease that we're like the resin channel
now and
every video is resin um
which they're not the way not every
video we purposely do some videos that
don't have friends and
just so i'd say like way like like a
third or less
our resin our resin yeah less than the
third
i'd say less than a third or resin which
you know
because the resin ones are often the
ones that like get pushed out to more
people yeah
but anyways one of the reasons that we
we
do a lot of resin is for that exact
reason it
it gives us a part of the video that is
going to be kind of fun and chaotic
experi and experimental
with relatively low stakes in terms of
like
physical danger to ourselves you know
you can't be like having a party and
having panic moments while you're using
the table saw you know
but like that's not good has a mental
breakdown during a resin pour
i mean i don't want you to have a mental
breakdown but
a minor yeah a minor moment of like what
is this
panic you know then it's just it's just
it's not life-threatening but any amount
of panic during
table saw operation isn't good isn't
good yeah not good at all that's one
reason we're drawn to resin a lot
yeah but i think going back to like the
the the trying to be perfect
versus trying new things that you aren't
good at it definitely has like
held us back from trying new things and
it's also
in a way lessened my happiness at the
end of the project
that i wasn't able to like keep on
iterating
and knowing that i probably won't be
able to keep on iterating
yeah on it because there's so many
things where
like we do enough for the video and we
might have that itch to do more but like
we can't make another video about it now
one thing we have started doing is live
streaming
like we wanted to try making cheese
again because we learned
new things from people in the comments
we knew we couldn't do a video
another like a second cheese video so
soon after but we did a cheese live
stream yeah
and we like doing flow acrylic so we did
a flow acrylic live stream and
you know we have other live streams
lined up in the future that we
might revisit some things on so that is
a good way to to kind of go back to it
and like take lessons learned and do it
better so yeah i'm glad that we have
that at least because
i do i don't know i do do you want to
talk about the specific example you're
talking about without giving too many
details because it's a video that's not
out yet
yeah i mean the video that we're filming
right now like
as an artist i wanted to do more and i
wanted to do
better and i know that i could have done
better and
having to stop like you know just
because like
we we've done enough for the video and
it's time to get editing now
um you know again like if we did more
iterations that would make kaitlyn's job
harder
it would probably make the video less
good um it would kind of like
weaken the successes that we did have
but at the same time i feel like we're
stopping
sooner than our maximum potential for
this new technique
yes but like in terms of
what the video is promising no in terms
of our own
like artistic itch that wants to make it
the perfect thing to hang in our house
yeah we are stopping early
in terms of that and and without giving
too much away it's
it's a art project that involves paint
and a very specific technique
and the things we want to do to some of
these that we just have this like itch
to do
don't have anything to do with that
technique which is why it would like
water down the video but like we want to
do it and maybe we will maybe later yeah
i think it was a live stream or like
honestly like you know as we keep on
trying
all these things so many of them are fun
yeah
i would just do them if i had the energy
and time
yeah i might do them just because well
we did do a few extra pieces i didn't
know if we were going to say that
but like you know i would want to do
them just in the future for fun so we
might
do that if we like you know do a few
less projects and we get free time for
ourselves and we just
do it art for fun do art for fun
yeah and like we are having fun with all
the things that we do
but i think it's a good sign when um
you know we do something for a video and
then we finish filming the video
and we're not going to film anymore and
we're like you want to do a couple more
just because
yeah before we release that's a good
sign i feel like that's a good sign
that like you know we we've we've
continued to develop our channel in a
direction where we like what we're doing
that's a very good sign yeah yeah but
like looking backwards so it's like i
know we mentioned the upcoming project i
wish we could have done more
we mentioned the pop sockets what about
other projects are there any other
projects thinking backwards that you
might have wanted to do
iterate more or try more things with
um i can pull up our channel
i have a few okay you can do say yours
first
for me um i think that the
painting with air cannon i wish we could
have like you know
denim jacket denim jacket painting with
the air cannon i feel like
we could have maybe done more there you
know learn from the colors that we used
you know maybe done like layering or
something like that
um but it could have also made things a
lot worse and i think that's another
thing that holds us back
yeah you don't want to make it from from
like okay this is this good there's a
good ending point
if i do any more it might just make it
worse and that's that's a
risky face with any art project at any
point because like
i always have a hard time knowing when
to stop but like you know with that one
i felt like
we could have maybe done more i think i
think for the most part
the the ones where i might feel the need
to keep going are more the art related
ones just because like that's something
that i'm a perfectionist
yep about yeah so i think the art
related ones are the ones that
that tend to get me more than like a a
build
yeah also like looking back at the bob
ross
paintings those were so fun but also
like
oh like doing oil painting for our very
first time
as a video like
like that that was like looking back at
it that's kind of like a
you know gutsy move that's an
interesting example though because like
i think because it was our first time it
made for a more interesting
it made for a much more interesting
video video yeah and
again sometimes we'll get comments from
people being like why don't you do more
research
you know or like test things out before
you start filming
be more serious do better and at the
same time it's like
but that's not the full point you know
yeah like i think it's it's funnier
i think most of you guys most of you
guys who are listening to this
understand
and stuff but i think that like people
coming in fresh
may not realize that this is our very
first time or our second time doing an
oil painting
and we don't know what we're doing we
don't know the techniques
you know we don't know how much titanium
white to put on the background
like we don't know the the pressures we
don't know how to use the palette knife
anyways
that's going into one too much also some
experiments
are just bound to be failures from the
beginning
like the the concrete resin gem yes
i'm gonna sorry i keep stopping you to
give background but especially on these
older videos
yeah i just feel like i need to give
context if we're gonna talk about it we
tried to mix
concrete and resin it didn't work yeah
it doesn't work at all it doesn't work
at all
so much failure in that video in the end
we made some like
decent-ish pieces but like
okay none of them were that great but we
learned
lessons we learned lessons and i think
that's another video
where like if we had to let our fear of
failure influence us too much we just
never would have done it
and we're like okay we'll just
experiment and see what happens and
well it wasn't the best
um but i think that
in the future looking at all of those
and you know how we think about them and
like looking backwards i think that like
i'm glad that we tried all of them i'm
still very happy with the videos we made
but i do i do
like that we now have live streaming as
a way to explore
and do things again yeah because like it
was something that always bothered me to
a certain degree
yeah and i know that there's a lot of
channels
and we've done it to a small extent
where they'll
like revisit things that they've done
before we always feel the need that if
we're revisiting
it or for revisiting something we're
adding drastically different
factors to the video so that wasn't
always the case think about um
a resin or a geode the geode series the
three geode videos
no but that is that is the case because
the very first
in the series was just us doing our very
first small scale experiments with resin
that was its own video the second was
doing resonance
resin that's the first reason the second
video in that series was doing
the geode the flat geode slices and the
third one we built a whole table out of
it using a
a cookie a wood cookie maybe that's
something that we do again
though like like um that only works if
each part is
big enough to be some video that that's
what i'm thinking
in the future maybe what we do is we
like you know for the opel pop socket
maybe we could have done one where we
just messed with opel
and came up with different ways to do
opal and then the second video was like
applying opal to the opal pop socket
now that we're experts but but here yeah
hear me out yeah
that second video would be super boring
that second video would be super boring
if it was just like okay guys
uh as you saw in our last video we
learned how to make opal
now we apply it to this tiny circle
done done you know what i mean so like
okay that's not the best example because
like double pops
big projects like the whole thing was
figuring out
the opal-ish look the pops like it was
just an excuse to
you know do it yeah do it yeah it was
just the object that we were applying
the opal to
so i don't really have any good examples
i think examples have to be bigger
examples
so like i could probably if i'm
if i'm going through our our projects
um so like some of our uh
bigger room makeovers we could have
broken those into multiple things like
we did a guest room makeover
and as part of that makeover we built an
entire desk technically we probably
could have made a whole video out of the
desk
but we we made a really simple desk so
that we could fit it into that video if
we hadn't made a very
complex desk we could have broken it out
but then we would be making a very
complex desk so we didn't have time to
do that it's a conundrum
yeah yeah it is it is interesting though
how do you think
um like
all of this doing having to do
videos not having the time to fully do
research not wanting to fully do
research
and not being able to continue as far as
you want in some cases how do you think
that has affected
your levels of perfectionism
as a person oh that's tough
because outside of youtube and making
and all of that
you know before we did this i didn't
have much perfectionism
because i didn't finish many things
[Laughter]
i'm trying to unfinished art yeah i'm
trying to like figure out how to say
that but like you know there were some
art that
you know art projects that i got really
drawn into and i really would finish
but like oftentimes i just didn't have
enough time to put in the amount of
effort that we're putting in right now
and in general
we are doing so much more and you know
putting in so much more time and i
really appreciate that
um but yeah before like you know i'm
thinking like you know
when we were working i just didn't have
much time and i think that
you know over the years things really
have changed when it comes to
trying new things and you know like
you know being a perfectionist about
things um you know obviously when we
were kids
would try whatever and we wouldn't worry
about perfectionism
because we were kids yourself huh speak
for yourself oh really
for me i'll just like try whatever even
if i
wasn't sure if i'd be good for you you
didn't do it unless you knew you were
going to be good no i would do it but i
would still be a perfectionist about it
so like like give me an example i don't
know it depends on the thing most of my
things are kind of like art related
because that's a lot of what i
did yeah for fun yeah you know but
i didn't i don't really have any
memories of being like oh i want to try
that but i won't
because i don't think i'll be able to do
it perfectly
really interesting because for me i'd
like disassemble things and not put them
back together again
i would try building things and give up
halfway just to like experiment with
springs and magnets i'll just like
half do things and i wouldn't finish it
because like like the
the finished part wasn't the purpose it
was like the play the experimentation or
whatever
so when i was younger i just i had no
fear of like
perfectionism or failure because it was
all about experimentation but for you
you had that when you were younger oh no
i'm not saying that i had a fear
of failure like i said it didn't hold i
don't have memories of it holding me
back from like
trying a hobby or something that i was
interested in
but if you were doing it you were going
to do it if i was the best you could
yeah and finish it and stuff if it was
something i mean
not for everything only for stuff that i
felt like it mattered like
um you know like if i was really trying
on some art but i also like my brother
and i would just do like request
drawings
yeah and those were like derpy little
doodles and that was the point of them
yeah you know but i do remember having
perfectionistic tendencies
about things that i really cared about
yeah even when i was pretty young i
think
for me in college
my like free time got a lot more
restricted and especially after college
free time was even more restricted and i
think the the lack of time is what
made like everything
that i did feel more like
precious like like that it had to be
worth it that like
like if i wasn't doing it well was i
wasting my time
yeah you know i think that's when it
like switched for me
yeah i feel that like up until high
school
i would just like you have time to kill
like at your parents house
have time to kill i'd like do bad photo
shopping
i'd like do bad photography
you know i'll just do things even though
i didn't really have the
highest hopes that they would turn out
well just to
just because i was curious yeah but i
think that that
started being restricted as soon as i
entered college
and it really started opening up again
when we started making videos
and the whole point was trying things
even if there was
going to be some failure yeah i think i
think
one change that all of this like having
the channel
has had on me is i've just transferred
my perfectionism
so it's not about the project anymore
and i i put all that perfectionist
energy towards my effort
yeah and that's why caitlyn asks all of
our videos because i would give up
most of the way through you didn't give
up you were just
i'd be okay with less i'd be okay with
less perfection yeah yeah
it's so funny because like we'll review
one of my edits
and i'm like that's great i have like 40
notes like
things have changed and i'm like did you
see anything you think i should change
it evan's like nope
i loved it
yeah that's so true but yeah but i i
actually
i think because i've transferred it to
the edits i think i
actually get less of that
itch to like do another round
or do one more iteration for the project
because like
i'm like in in my head i'm like well
this is the perfect amount for the edit
like we have our beginning middle end
it's good even if i
am only like 80 percent happy with end
result i think that's really interesting
too because like
when like in in terms of like
responsibilities
of evan and caitlyn like as the business
one of my things that like i kind of
lead is like
real you know prepping the project
researching the project ordering all the
supplies
figuring out the design figuring out
like the logistics and
and all of that so i'm more tied in
terms of the success
to the outcome yeah of the project
itself whereas you are
like like you said think about the
success is about that it
yeah that is interesting speaking of
perfectionism and half-formed ideas
it's time for a game it's been a long
time since we played a game do we have
music
i think so we'll play it now
[Music]
i forgot how long it is it's been a long
time since we did a game it's been a
long time since we played a game
and this is a game that i thought of
part way and i'm gonna
explain it to you and we're gonna figure
it out together live
great so it's something that caitlin and
i do
all the time so it should be very easily
okay um
caitlin and i have like five songs
that we make up songs to all the time
like five tunes that we make
um let's get down to business i think we
have more than five
um a whole bunch of like christmas songs
yeah
so we're like what are the some of the
songs that come to mind
that we like make up tunes too i don't
know
all i can think of now is let's get down
do this
so what what i'm gonna do okay is i'm
gonna do request songs
okay oh god i'm nervous because like we
do this all the time it's always
impromptu and it has to be impromptu
to be as good bad as we want okay so i'm
gonna do the first request
um song to caitlyn let's get down to
business but make it about
food can you give me a specific food
um uh pasta right
whenever you're ready but it has to be
within 10 seconds
okay let's go make some pasta
cause we're out of buns
did they send me noodles
when i asked
nothing rhymes with puns it's so hard to
come up with rhymes on the spot
see for me this is another perfectionist
thing let me do the same thing everyone
does not rhyme
i just wouldn't rhyme and i i'll like
extend the song
and make it wrong and it bothers caitlyn
and it's great
okay did they pick up did they send me
noodles this will be a collaborative
thing no no i'm gonna start again
completely fresh about pasta okay
is this good content let's get down to
dinner
to defeat my hunger
did they send me noodles when i
asked for ramen
this is the saddest song you've ever
heard
and i don't apologize at all
that's it you gotta get back to noodles
okay but this is this is something that
we do i'll
make carbonara out of you
good job good job okay do you have a
request a request song for me
okay um so i didn't prepare all the like
tunes that i know
you'll know really well but i know
disney ones you got so
let's do i can show you the world yeah
yeah
that's a good one that's a great one and
my topic is
um sorry i didn't prepare uh cats
but a lot of our songs are about dub so
i don't want it to be
jube centric because you already had
know a lot of rhymes i can show you her
paws
little cute toe beans
i mean i can just keep on going yeah you
said no cats
no i said no i didn't want it to be like
jube specific because we already
do a lot of jew ones but that's so good
just go for it
no it's already like once the song ends
for me you can't
you can't continue no so your song is
two lines yes that counts
the best two lines that have been sung
on this podcast
okay so does that mean it's your turn to
give me one no no no you can get i'll
give you a redo
but i can still do that song i can show
you the world
but make it about make it
about um
uh caitlyn's looking around our room
right now scrambling for like something
to to
sing about oh yeah well i want to pick i
can come up with so many things
oh yeah but you pre-thought about that
no i didn't at all
i'm coming into it like at this point
we're equal
um okay what do you want to do
i can show you the resin
shining shimmering
what's that on the floor is that resin
or is it some poop a whole new craft
tons of projects for me and you
cause when we're in the shop
the resin might drop and then we get
more resin
on the floor
oh i like the duet yeah if you feel like
if you like the rules are if you feel
inspired jump in okay
just go ahead and jump in because that's
often what happens that's more
that's pretty real life right that's
pretty real life okay
so now you want to give me a tune and a
a topic
um disney ones are pretty good but i
feel like we've done like a couple
disney's a couple disney's let's do a
christmas
okay um
what's what's our frequent this like
christmas songs that we do
i mean a lot of them like jingle bells
or
i don't know jingle bells it is jingle
bells
but make it about leds
rgb leds rgb
leds they're the best slides
they make any project cool and then your
house is rainbow
rgb leds put em on your things
they'll make anything futuristic and
then you
glow i tried to embrace
my oven there and not not working yeah
just just go with the like
freestyle freestyle
wait should we rap no no okay this
concludes
this this game segment back to the
podcast
oh that was fun though that's a good
little like mini game yeah yeah i
thought you could do it for the whole
thing no no
annoying no no super annoying but that's
what i thought it'd be great for like a
little accent
every now and then a little like
freestyle
game that we can cause like cause we can
do that
at any time with no preparation needed
and there's no
need for like fear of copyright because
we like doing
games around songs like guess the song
or whatever we've done a lot of games
like that in the past in the past yeah
back in the past but then um
those require preparation and this
requires no preparation it's all about
lack of preparation perfect perfect
but for now it's time to go to thing of
the week
oh guys my thing of the week has been
something i have wanted
my entire life you guys know baby
computer
i'm holding a baby computer on screen
right now it's a tiny computer
it's a tiny computer that sits in your
lap it's really cute because you're
holding it close to the camera
yeah now it actually looks like really
big it looks really big but it's it's
it's so small you can fit it into a big
pocket it's like the size of your face
it's it's it's pretty cute um baby
computer is like a good
little portable workstation and stuff
like that but that's not the thing of
the week
that's another thing of the week but i
just wanted to like bring like context
and background
to how excited i am about my thing of
the week this time so i've
i've always liked many computers i've
always wanted them but
one of the reasons why i always wanted
them is to play games on them
new little computer it's just about the
same size it's a little bit thicker a
little bit taller
but it has a built-in game controller to
it
yeah it has left and right shoulder
buttons
um uh bumper buttons it has um
you know an a b x y do you want to say
what it is
so that people can i mean well
it was just launched on a fundraising
crowd funding raising campaign so
i'm not sure if you can buy it yet but
it has been
so great um because you know in the
evenings we try
to take like 30 minutes maybe an hour
to just relax and hang out and
my thing that i like to do generally is
to play games
um and caitlyn likes to read so kaelin
reads on the couch
and i'm in our office playing games and
i
want to be with her yeah i want to be
with her and the jew
me and you are having a snuggle party
yeah and i'm just in here like
in the dark in the computer room
and that's not as fun so now i can take
my gaming with me
this this is this has really impressed
me
i have thrown a whole bunch of games at
it and every single one has worked i
mean
i'm not playing like crisis or like
i don't know what the like the the game
of the day is where like it's it's a
really tough game to play
but i think this is more for couch
gaming
honestly that couch game you're sitting
at a
you know if you're going to play like a
really intense game you're probably
going to be at your computer with a
mouse yeah i wouldn't you know just just
because in general i like
mouse and wasd for first person shooters
because like
you just can't beat the precision of a
mouse but there are
so many great games that are perfect for
this like
stardew valley oh would be amazing for
this
um like chill games yeah chill games i i
just recently started playing bastion
which is like a perfect game to play on
here there's a whole bunch of games that
i've
downloaded and started playing on here
and um
they're they're really fun and you know
you can
also download emulators and play them if
you do it legally
and all of that that's all i'll say
about that
because you know emulation is a touchy
topic for
for some people and stuff but um it
totally works with that if that's your
jam um but it's it's really cool
that that um you know all of the
components that are required to play
video games can be shrunk down
this small it has huge intakes and
outputs for
airflow it's a computer um you know
yeah yeah you can use it you can turn it
into mouse mode
and the joysticks are now a mouse
and the bumpers are now left and right
click
oh cool so you can move around and use
it as a computer too
i know it's so crazy anyways that's my
thing of the week i'm really excited
i've been having a blast
um playing on it and i just wanted to
share that excitement with you guys
now you have two baby computers two baby
computers i'm gonna have a [ __ ] and
baby computer you have to come up with
different names for them
we'll probably just call them both baby
cookies baby gaming computer and baby
business computer baby business computer
baby business
okay so my thing of the week is not
really a new thing but we recently
finally hung it so i've been thinking
and you were just singing
about them i was it's an led
quote-unquote
neon rainbow wall sign
it's so thank you it's so cute i got it
for i think this past christmas we had
it like leaning on our kitchen counters
um but i just didn't know where to put
it
and we finally hung it in the office and
it's right above my desk so i see it
when i glance up at the wall and it's
just so cute
it has the style of like a neon stop a
neon stein
a neon sign but it's leds um and how it
does it is the
the leds are kind of like on their side
and then they
shine into a reflector and diffuser and
then into this big plastic
strip it almost looks like a really
thick glow stick
that is bent into every like
uh color of the rainbow yeah
and it has a lot of advantages over
traditional neon
tubes yeah it does make a noise doesn't
make a noise it's reliable
low energy low heat low like it's it's
it's great lots of advantages yeah so
i've got it on amazon
um so i'll put a link but it's just so
cute it's so cute
and it makes me like you know we've been
trying to like take care of our office a
little bit more since we spent so much
time in here
there's only so much we can do because
we have two massive desks
taking up 98 of the room
but it's what we can do um uh so
we'll have links to those two in the
description of today's podcast
um and we want to thank you guys for
tuning in we really appreciate you guys
spending your time with us um if you
enjoyed today's
podcast maybe consider giving us a five
star review it's an ongoing prank that
we have we want to get our
podcast up in the charts so that someone
downloads it and is very confused
and we'll look forward to seeing you in
the next episode
[Music]